it was tense i was in the courtroom this
morning for britney's conservatorship
hearing and
now brittany wasn't there but of course
her attorney was and there was a big
disagreement between him
and the attorneys for britney's dad it
boils down to this
jamie and his team want to hear directly
from brittany
not her lawyer
britt's been on a posting spree that's
her dancing
dress casual and modeling a lingerie
look but behind the scenes in court
papers obtained
by e.t the singer wants to hire new
attorneys who specialize in
conservatorship
issues to represent her case but her dad
is opposed the reason jamie says they're
too expensive and claims that britney is
going through an alarming amount of
money
[Music]
now the singer's estate is worth an
estimated 57
million dollars but jamie's legal team
claims
the burn rate that the estate is
experiencing is high
this is made even more troubling because
quote miss spears has determined
not to work at this time so is britney
spears going to war
with her dad well the real showdown is
expected to happen here a week from
[Music]
today